a warm welcome on a bitterly cold
washington day for the first gulf leader
to visit the white house since joe biden
took over qatar has become a key partner
on several issues impacting the u.s this
past year our partnership with qatar
was has been central to many
of our most vital interests
qatar was a key player during the u.s
withdrawal from afghanistan still has
communications with the taliban and
hosts thousands of refugees who still
have to be processed before they move to
america
with additional assistance on iran yemen
the palestinians the president has
decided to give qatar special status and
i'm notifying congress that i will
designate qatar as a major non-nato ally
to reflect the importance the importance
of our relationship
qatar becomes the 18th country to be
given the ally status it provides
important benefits in areas of trade
defence and security cooperation the
emir insists qatar was and is happy to
help a country it has been an ally with
for 50 years we're very proud that we
managed to evacuate tens of thousands of
people of and of afghanistan of course
we have other issues as well that we're
going to talk about the equal rights of
the palestinian people
and other issues
in the region so you know we're very
happy and proud of this great
relationship
russia's build up on the ukrainian
border continues to be the most urgent
issue for the white house if moscow
decides to invade sanctions will follow
there's a worry russia will respond by
shutting off gas supplies to key
european allies qatar could help divert
supplies of its own liquid natural gas
to ease the pressure and nearby the
qatari purchase of 34 new boeing freight
jets was signed with an option for 50
more passenger liners from the american
company
qatar was frozen out in the early days
of the trump presidency but qatari
officials insist it has been a steady
and reliable partner for the united
states in an unsteady part of the world
and with its links and connections it
could help solve some problem issues for
the united states
and its president
alan fisher al-jazeera at the white
house